[Music]
back in late 2018 a new Dragonball game
was revealed named Dragonball game
projects Z action RPG thankfully that
was only a working title which became
Dragonball Z Kakarot there has been
countless attempts to retell Goku story
in video game form but Kakarot seems
like the perfect combination of DBZ law
storytelling role-playing and of course
action so much action I've been looking
into this take on Dragon Ball Z and I'm
so enthused about it I have to post
everything down I've learned into a list
in a YouTube video so write in the
comments what year you first encountered
Dragon Ball Z and if you ready he has 20
things you should know about Dragon Ball
Z
[Music]
we'll kick off with the more obvious
things and we'll work towards the most
secretive aspects you should know first
of all Dragon Ball Z Kakarot is an RPG
don't get me wrong it has plenty of
fighting but at its core it's about
learning the world you live in
traveling by vehicle or flying to each
destination talking to other characters
and NPCs and reliving everything from
the anime I feel this is important as
many gamers especially those new to
Dragonball want to try every game which
releases but fighting games even the
best ones can be a little daunting with
an action RPG the X version of Dragon
Ball Z is the most accessible to date so
keep in mind
RPG first fighting game second or in
other words will be underpowered in the
early game and slowly learn new skills
working your ass off to improve before
becoming an unstoppable juggernaut in
the late game continuing from this point
the core story told in Dragon Ball Z
Kakarot is completely canon a faithful
retelling of events from the anime from
the Saiyan saga through to the start of
Eve's adventure and everything in
between but get this the developers have
added a few extra things such as
additional content and context to every
event to enrich the law maybe we'll see
something from another character's
perspective maybe an additional line of
dialogue which better explains events
those have been lucky enough to play the
game thus far have been shouting from
the rooftops about the depth of the
storytelling content available here as
an addition to the core plot like every
other great RPG you've played side
quests are here to add context and a
little catharsis to proceedings the plot
points from the anime which detract from
the main story have been hidden away in
plain sight
via character interactions in the game
but once again there's a curveball which
hardcore DBZ fans should know about
non-canon missions as we are in a fully
fleshed out world it's impossible to add
everything intended by writer Akira
Toriyama this is where there is a
distinct disconnect between the core
story and many side quests simply put
some of the side quests have been
invented especially for the game for
example there's a way to fish here and
how do we do it with Goku's tail if I
remember rightly it was cut off
permanent
but luckily he keeps it inside his
Jersey to bring out whenever he wants to
fish okay it's a bit strange but but
stick with it it's not exactly canon but
it's a great way to reintroduce elements
from the series which don't really play
an important part anymore because this
is an open world to some degree and time
passes within the game which is possible
to meet some characters earlier than
first suggested in the manga this will
introduce backstories to characters as
you see what they were like through sub
quests again keep in mind that these are
not necessarily canon but added
backstories which should help us
understand their choices later in the
story I've used the term open world a
couple of times already when asked if
the world is fully open the devs gave oh
yes no answer so to help clarify this
the world is indeed separated into huge
sections huge zones and planet regions
which are not all sewn together you
can't walk from A to Z dynamically to
access many of these Goku who needs to
fly straight up into the air and far
enough away to look down upon the world
he can then choose a region he wishes to
land in so see this as a useful fast
travel option so what can we expect from
these open-world elements when outside
of key battles well you can expect
fishing training punting training eating
training exploring training you get the
idea the world is filled with different
beings to fight like these dragon like
creatures which inhabit most places in
the early game at least the eating
mechanic is not for survival purposes
you won't be forced to dramatically
change how you play to monitor your
calorie intake
instead meals offer temporary buffs such
as flying speed healing rate and attack
powers the hunting element is the most
key here as it unlocks additional
abilities and exploration is pivotal to
finding those side quests which unlock
more character upgrades
both in the story section of the game
and in the upperworld elements many
tasks have been designed with one-off
minigames to mimic the anime as closely
as possible while still incorporating
video game mechanics for example when
Goku and piccolo go for their driving
licenses there's a minigame especially
for it another example is when playing
baseball
Dragon Ball Z Kakarot is going for a
home run with the RPG elements in this
game deep and varied throughout at this
point we all already know that we're
playing as legendary hero Goku
throughout the entirety of Dragon Ball Z
Kakarot well think again because other
playable characters have been confirmed
and each have unique skills the
confirmed playable characters so far are
Goku Son Gohan fierce rival slash best
friend piccolo and legendary Saiyan
Vegeta Gohan is all about short range
flurries of combat hand-to-hand fighting
is his thing but he also has those moves
you'd expect like mischenko Gohan's real
dad piccolo is defensively buffed and
has a huge pool of health and is all set
with his explosive wave which produces
an area of effect damage bubble great
for taking down large groups of foes
Vegeta is more focused towards ki blasts
and ranged combat but he can get in
there and fight on the inside too if he
needs to but the others are better
suited to that so there's an element of
tactics the characters you choose here's
something very cool - no not all quests
found in the open world can be accessed
by Goku missions will be hidden away at
only certain playable characters can
attain how cool is that so keep your
eyes open in-game a quick character swap
could open up another storyline and more
precious RPG goodness in addition to
this Goku is able to take support
characters with him up to two to be
precise and just as we saw with the
playable characters each supporting
character has unique skills in battle
for example Crillon is able to use solar
flare to blind enemies alone Goku to run
up and start a combo on contest it the
answer has a way to restrict enemy
movement via his spirit ball he can also
gain aggro from enemies which could help
if you find yourself near death ciaossu
has telekinesis to restrain enemies Tien
is another with a saw
a flair but he also has a try beam for
straight-up damage the skill is to
choose the right duo to take into the
right fight because of the next key
point those characters will actually
think for themselves when in battle
think of them as autonomous or
ai-controlled
but no they are constantly learning how
you fight to improve their own reactions
in battle
the devs aren't giving us everything
right away and holding back on support
and playable characters but have
suggested more can be added in updates
and DLC if the community want that if
the name doesn't give it away already
the dragonballs can be found and
collected in-game which in turn summons
Sharon from here using our wishes we can
actually will a foreign enemy back to
life basically we can fight an enemy for
a second time but with new conditions
and much more difficult beating these
bosses will reward Goku with items and
skills which will make his journey a
little easier this aspect brings in
replayability and good old what-if
scenarios with additional dialogue from
each of the characters and speaking of
dialogue do you prefer Dragon Ball Z
Kakarot oh if it's the latter you should
know from minute one the audio can be
switched to Japanese making the world
feel even more authentic there are many
original voice actors returning which
makes this option unmissable for the
hardcore fans I sadly cannot read
subtitles quick enough here so I'll
stick with good old English there's an
unwritten rule and Dragon Ball Z games
are made a new character must be
designed this time around Dragon Ball
creator Akira Toriyama has returned to
the franchise to introduce a brand new
character especially for Dragon Ball Z
Kakarot will soon meet bond you who
looks like a thick girl so I'm all up
for this formerly one of the ginyu force
this beaut will appear in a short
training mission which can be opened
early if you pre-ordered the games
hmm ultimately this will make the game a
little easier as you'll have an ability
bar before you should obtain that in the
game naturally I'm not sure how I feel
about that well we've started looking
down pre-order bonuses so let's jump in
with both feet in two versions of the
game in addition to the standard edition
you have the collectors deluxe
Ultimate editions to choose from the
deluxe version includes a cooking item
which Awards permanent key attack and HP
boosts and the season pass which will
add two more original stories and one
new Canon story later in the games
lifecycle the Ultimate Edition has all
of that plus a music pack of eleven
freaking awesome anime trucks to get you
groove on - and the Tau pi PI pillar
from spring 2020 hmm interesting
the collector's edition includes a
freaking diorama a steelbook of the
world those expansions we talked about
and the obligatory art book tough
choices to be made here which version
are you going for and while we're
speaking of versions of the game we
should note that there is no plans to
make a Nintendo switch version I know
I'm gutted - DBZ on the goal could have
been epic at launch Dragon Ball Z
Kakarot releases on ps4 Xbox one and PC
on January 17th which so happens to be
my birthday expect enhanced versions for
the ps4 Pro and Xbox one but to last
those details are yet to be shared as
I'm writing this so there we have it 20
things you should know about Dragon Ball
Z Kakarot until one week ago I was
completely new to this franchise but
I've quickly grown to understand why
it's such a long-running cultural
phenomenon I'm looking forward to
playing through the events of Dragon
Ball Z what about you I'd love to know
your thoughts I'm Adam from Playstation
grenade in a pleasure see you next time
[Music]
it's over 9000
what 9000